it was China's decision to expel three
Wall Street Journal reporters that
triggered a media brawl with the United
States the Chinese Communist Party said
the expulsion was retaliation for a
journal headline that labeled China as
the real sick man of Asia the reporters
had also worked on topics considered
sensitive by Chinese officials and their
visas were revoked as a result China
will not be a silent lamp to insults in
smearing in addition the newspaper
defended themselves with independence of
opinions from news stories they are
being unreasonable and shirking their
responsibilities the expulsion came
after the United States announced it
would treat China's state news media
outlets operating in America as arms of
the Chinese government in March
Washington said it would cut the quota
of Chinese nationals allowed to work at
the u.s. Offices of major Chinese
state-owned media the organization's
targeted includes sin wah China Radio
China Daily and the China Global
Television Network the move effectively
could force 60 Chinese citizens to leave
the United States I think normally in
these media matters there's a bit of
bloodletting and then it calms down but
you know maybe I'm being tensions
between the two countries have escalated
since Donald Trump came to office three
years ago with disputes ranging from
trade to accusations of Chinese spying
and American support for Taiwan analysts
say the global panic over the corona
virus epidemic has provided a new
opportunity for the u.s. to denounce the
Chinese Communist Party the media
landscape is yet another battleground it
reminds me of the old Cold War spy games
you know where we reduce their number of
diplomats they reduced our number of
diplomats you know journalists didn't
really want to go there but I think they
are now Washington says the latest media
restrictions on the Chinese controlled
media in the u.s. is in return for
Beijing's harsh treatment of
journalists but China hasn't ruled out
making the next move that message was
delivered on Twitter by a foreign
ministry spokesman who said the u.s.
kicked off the game now let's play Sarah
Clark al Jazeera Hong Kong